[Music]
unusual marriage news submitted by David
rjk party go calm down and IG because
he's a lazy [ __ ] he's not even
here today a lazy woman marries a train
station that she is loved for 36 years
oh she finally could be what the train
station that she's always been in love
with but she can't be with it because
the train station has to stay there I
know what she does I think when the
train comes by you should put your
vagina for the vibration on what are the
railroad tracks that's dirty why you've
done that before how do you know so
clearly because I know how your dirty
mind she's not in love with the Train
she's in love with the train station duh
don't be The Herald Santa Fe 45 years
old from San Diego
she married by Amtrak station faith
train station did she have friends and
family there they don't really go into
the wedding
how did she official last best [ __ ] I
think it's just between her and the
building they unified their love she's
not what did she do kiss a street light
I do
how did she consummate the mange she
does mention how she's alright so okay
so Carol she identifies herself as an
objective sexual which is a person who
sexually attracted to inanimate object
she gets horny oh yeah all that builds
it oh she's been love with that train
station station since she was nine years
old it's not a fetish guys it's real
it's like unrequited love though because
how does she know that transition loves
her back she feels the energy sounds
like rape to me she didn't even know
that she was an objective sexual until
she was 40 years old she went online as
she searched I hate that well yeah I am
in love with a building that's what she
she was in a previous relationship that
was about 18 months long but it was to a
live with the freeway she cheated on the
freeway with the [ __ ] train station
no she says that this train station is
do you one and only love in her life
it's her true love until she sees
another train station watch till she
goes to Japan oh she's gonna be a
[ __ ] cheater a bullet train though
there's so many fish in the sea
there's too many stations over there
don't settle where she goes to European
train oh my goodness
Oh were fun classy train station or she
wants that hood la train station damn
track the gate to us watch oh that's a
bad boy right there she named this train
station Daedra deidre and so that's her
name the train stations name Oh train
stations of Themis oh [ __ ]
so she is a lesbian I don't know they
talk about lesbianism or anything but we
got a label everything this one was just
in love with Street she's the one that's
at Daedra she didn't say date row yes no
she refers to the translation of the she
see I'm just following her lead yeah so
she's saying that they were in a
relationship or they started their
relationship in 2011 okay um and she's
saying they've been together for a while
six years yeah they've been together for
that long she's saying that when they
got married she stood there and told her
that she takes her as her partner and
she says that that was the happiest day
of their lives how does she feel
everyone's going in and out of her like
every day every hour like so many people
and does she live at the train station
no she doesn't live at the train station
she says that she takes a 45-minute bus
ride every single day to go see the
transition what does she do for a living
she is a volunteer support worker and so
she works with a lot of people that are
in emotional distress that's nice but
seems like she needs to support her yeah
she change her last name to be
scientific we'd get hurt
I like her fanny pack dating a trip is
she wearing a onesie with the fanny pack
the scent of a train and I know her as
my friend my life partner
my wife Daedra Santa Fe so if someone
was like leaning on her wife my wife
[Music]
when I have to go home I hated it but I
had to go home
she loved the energy there huh
[Music]
in the crack what's up with the PDA lady
get a row know where she got that it's
like a onesie with it can you watch no
not a can't buy a hoodie that looks
cause of one's health
person
is it all just the energy that she feels
I do what if someone else wants to marry
the translation like what is she gonna
do like she gonna fight them off Oh like
there's other people in this world that
have the object love thing right yeah
all these people safety they don't want
to leave San Pedro revenuers yeah or
like doorknobs or whatever right these
inanimate objects like there's a lot of
people so what if someone else is
feeling the energy at the train station
and also wants to marry that's gonna be
some that would be a that would be
actually pretty good job oh yeah she
mentioned Erica ISIL which she famously
married the Eiffel Tower in Paris
back in 2007 so she's saying like with
her like she got banned from ever
visiting the Eiffel Tower because she
would show like her she was humping one
of the ladies yeah it was actually that
something like that so like so she's
saying apparently thing she doesn't want
the same thing happening to her and they
drive so they don't want to be separated
so she keeps her her relationship with
secret so she doesn't tell the security
guards or anything that you know she's
involved in this relationship but she ya
freak how you gonna try to [ __ ] one of
the Eiffel Tower legs once you build it
you see how big it is I know like how do
you want that me it's like a huge yeah
yeah but she's saying that she doesn't
like to publicly show any affection
between her and Daedra because she's
saying that she has more respect than
that cuz that she's like why like I
wouldn't have sex with the human in
public so what am I gonna do the same
with her so she's like I have more but
she goes out and I didn't do it and does
it ya know
no one's there no she says she has
mental sex with her
that's dumb I wish I could have mental
such a thing that the first time how
they consummated the marriage that she
went between that spot it was in the
video her favorite spot where the two
walls meet and
she brought out her deal that was over
there the [ __ ] rubbing it on the wall
no and nothing like that but this she
was just like leaning up against the
wall and that she could feel the
vibrations and the energy to the point
where she orgasm all oh sure lucky her I
want to feel that what if I start
[ __ ] falling in love with barbell
those big big crash make me feel part of
barbell though just the whole structure
yeah the whole building and then the
next thing you do is you see me like
[ __ ] one of your walls and well what
would happen if they decide to move that
location I'll try to find a way to stay
there yeah that's wrong yeah you see me
climbing up to the skull making up
making out with it they're saying that
you know this objective sexual thing
like they don't know like expertly
saying like they don't really know what
it classifier does whether it's a
sexuality or a fetish or is just a
mental condition cuz honestly the only
difference between her and like a la
homeless person is that she has a job
you hear the same [ __ ] you go to like
[ __ ] Skid Row there's guys all up on
the floor
touching talking to the streetlights
well I love you sir kind gentlemen sweep
me off my feet it's the same [ __ ] they
get into arguments with our loved ones
but it's a meet it's a it's a meter
reciting poems so a fire hydrant I think
some of those people will be on drugs
though I agree with you yeah that's not
like a normal I feel like that maybe
some homeless people but then that's not
the majority of most homelessness get
wrong ones there they're special I see
them all the time they're my neighbors
kind of jealous though they get to camp
every day oh my god you in camping you
could camp anytime you want
I know but you're scared because like
when I see them I'm like to have you
guys are so brave what do you want it's
not that easy you can't just say don't
be afraid you try to go to skid row and
cab there I know but like that's
different it's easier said than done
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding News and if you guys
want to share a story there's a link
down in the description box below where
you can submit your story if you guys
want to watch more episodes click right
up here
[Music]